[Musique]
c'est fini après une enquête qui aura
duré 3 129 jours la sphère peugeot a
trouvé son dénouement
les policiers ont amené à paris raymond
rolland et le reste de la bande
la blonde inglis bodine qui cachait son
visage et roland moumié mesic enfouie
sous son imperméable visage découvert
pierre larche et le dur est sans doute
l'organisateur grappes et jean-simon
rotman l'étudiant qui prétend ignorer la
provenance de l'argent
ravisseurs des complices tous sont sous
clé les enquêteurs peuvent maintenant
reconstituer les détails du rapt du
petit eric qu'on voit ici rendu à ses
parents après la remise des 50 millions
si l'on connaissait les détails de
l'enlèvement
l'arrivée du ravisseur par une brèche
dans la sève au golf de saint cloud où
l'enfant jouer tous les jours et leur
départ par la barrière on sait
maintenant que c'est dans cette maison
retirée des pieds russe qu'eric a été
séquestré
on a aussi retrouvé dans une voiture qui
stationnée dans un garage parisien une
partie une toute petite partie de la
rançon
6 millions d'anciens francs l'un autres
millions si l'on compte le prix payé
pour acquérir la vieille ferme de reuil
sur brèche future retraite peut-être
pour d'autres crimes
le plus singulier sans douté que megève
ou une ville a abrité les vacances de la
famille peugeot était en même temps
l'asile de la banque qui se logeait dans
ce chalet des six enfants où furent
arrêtés à mont-rolland et une glisse
bodine on dit même qu'au restaurant la
ferme ils ont pu dîner à des tables
voisines à versailles
le commissaire denis a remis ses prix
aux juges renard chargé de l'instruction
[Musique]
bien marché va devoir méditer sur une
carrière dans le rapt du petit peugeot
n'était pas le début d'une glisse bodine
fausse miss danemark sur les dangers de
l'argent trop facile l'étudiant rotman
sur un thème analogues
quant à raymond renan puisqu'il méditer
sur le caractère odieux du crime qui
consiste à mettre en jeu la vie d'un
enfant
[Musique]
l'homme vient d'enregistrer un nouveau
record de vitesse
porté par un b 52 l'avion spatial
américain x 15 après avoir atteint 22
mille mètres d'altitude a volé à 4200 64
km heure
l'appareil qui s'est posé sur ses skis
dans le désert de californie aurait mis
neuf minutes 37 secondes pour passer de
la verticale de paris et celle de
marseille
il peut encore faire beaucoup mieux sans
pilote le commandant bob white qui est
aujourd'hui l'homme le plus vite du
monde a échappé pendant 27 secondes de
la pesanteur
[Musique]
vivre c'est aussi pour ceux qu'on nomme
les diminuer physique la possibilité de
retrouver une vie active
monsieur bernard chesneau ministre de la
santé publique a inauguré à quetigny
dans l'eure le centre joseph arbitres y
qui répond justement à ce but et qui est
le premier du genre en france tout en
poursuivant leur rééducation les
paraplégiques peuvent ici serait adapté
au travail industriel et redevenir des
citoyens à part entière
[Applaudissements]
parent attention vous le savez les
jeunes enfants ont trop tendance à
porter à leur bouche tout ce qu'ils
trouvent
mais ce simple geste n'est pas seulement
contraire à l'hygiène il peut être bien
plus grave
il l'est d'ailleurs trop souvent pour le
constater il suffit de parcourir les
journaux pas de semaine kino relate un
drame de cette espèce intoxication
empoisonnement c'est la nécessité du
transport immédiat à l'hôpital encore
peut-on s'estimer heureux quand ces
accidents se limite à l'hospitalisation
or ces drames vous les côtoyer
quotidiennement pour que vous laissiez
les produits d'entretien à la portée de
vos enfants
c'est à dire le plus souvent à leur
hauteur au de javel soude acide mur y'a
tic
le bon ordre peut-être un autre résonner
dans le placard inaccessibles les
produits ménagers sont à l'abri des
convoitises
mais
et puis songer aussi à un autre danger
plus grave encore les médicaments dans
un tiroir ouvert ils sont tellement
tentant ces petits tubes tellement
tentant ces bonbons qui n'en sont pas
quand on ne sait pas lire n'est ce pas
rien ne réfrène la gourmandise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et puis il y à la table de chevet et
c'est somnifères qu'on est tenté de
laisser à portée de sa main ce qu'il est
mais du même coup à la portée de toutes
les mains par an ne laissez jamais
traîner de produits pharmaceutiques
or de l'armoire à pharmacie mais pensez
aussi que les enfants de manta d'astuces
et qu'il y aille mieux qu'une porte
fermée une porte fermée à clé
comme lis pas demain dans les journaux
encore un enfant empoisonné
match à mohacs est roi
[Applaudissements]
deux combattants ne se font pas plus de
cadeaux que deux lutteurs sur harry tous
les coups sont permis surtout les
copains
voici un magnifique et tremblements
comme au catch l'essentiel maintenant
c'est de ne plus lâcher prise
on se sert de ses pattes comme d'une
paire de boue l'adversaire ne s'en sort
pas il sera bien obligé d'abandonner le
combat sur décision de l'arbitré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
meron tout le monde descend et même
beaucoup plus vite que certains
concurrents ne le voudrait cette épreuve
c'est la dernière grande compétition
internationale de la saison
il s'agit du kandahar que la plupart des
champions considère un peu comme un
véritable championnat du monde un
championnat du monde qui ressemble
étrangement pour le moment un concours
de chute type
[Musique]
il paraît que ce n'est pas la meilleure
méthode pour gagner l'épreuve il vaut
mieux rester sur ses skis pour franchir
la ligne d'arrivée
[Musique]
passons maintenant aux choses sérieuses
avec guy périllat
[Musique]
perrillat c'est l'homme qui a gagné
toutes les grandes descentes de la
saison
alors pourquoi pas celle là
il n'a aucun complexe avec lui pas de
chute à craindre il a prodigieux sens de
l'équilibré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à cent à l'heure il avale toutes les
bosses sans perdre une seconde
merveilleuse position
[Musique]
m
malgré son sourire périllat a trompé
tout son monde il n'a pas gagné la
descente du camp d'art il ya deux
vainqueurs l'allemand wagner bergen
numéro 10 et l'italien alberti numéro 7
avant le départ du slalom guy périllat
n'est pas très rassurée pour la première
fois cette année il n'est pas certain de
gagner le combiné c'est à dire le
classement conjugués de la descente et
du slalom l'autrichien pepi stiegler
prend le départ c'est un concurrent très
dangereux pour périr
de fait ils glissent entre les portes
avec beaucoup de vélocité sans accrocher
une seule à vous de jouer maintenant
monsieur périllat vous savez à quoi vous
en tenir
le champion français a l'air de vouloir
forcer le destin
[Musique]
malchance perry y accroche deux portes
qui vivent père de l'equilibre ses
pépites spiegler qui gagne mais pas avec
suffisamment d'avancé cependant puisque
finalement périllat remporte quand même
le camp d'art le champion français est
bien le skieur le plus extraordinaire de
tous les temps
il
[Musique]